all right i have a few things today to
catch you up on first and foremost we
have been waiting to see what happens in
georgia with the subpoenas of republican
senator lindsey graham and trump's
former lawyer rudy giuliani with rudy
giuliani his lawyer recently told the
judge in new york he is not fit to
travel for medical reasons he can't fly
down to which the judge said there's
other ways to get down to atlanta you
could take an uber you could take a car
there's other ways to get down there you
could take a train
that is pending with rudy giuliani
however yesterday
lindsey graham or wednesday rather
lindsey graham was supposed to show up
at a courthouse in fulton county and he
did not 46 news from atlanta reporting
senator lindsey graham a no-show at
scheduled fulton county court appearance
this is what we know right now lindsey
graham didn't show up
he was subpoenaed to testify in a
special grand jury investigation looking
at whether trump and others broke laws
when they tried to overturn the results
of joe biden's win in georgia in 2020.
lindsay's one of the people trump allies
that the district attorney fannie willis
wants to question
graham said previously he would fight
the subpoena his attorneys say the probe
is politically motivated and graham was
indeed ordered to testify on august 2nd
the petition states that the state of
georgia will pay travel expenses and
witness fees
um lindsay didn't show up
now this thing of political motivation
this is another one of their catch-alls
that they're using and hopefully it
won't be allowed to stand the idea what
they want us to hear when they say this
is politically motivated is there's no
empirical or factual basis to even be
doing this when they go
these are politically motivated
investigations they want you to believe
the person doing the investigation is so
blinded by political bias that they are
investigating or prosecuting or doing or
subpoenaing
on the basis of their political beliefs
not on the basis of their responsibility
as law enforcement and prosecution of
course that's absurd
but more importantly these are alleged
political crimes if you try
to
overturn an election
and have the guy who lost given the
electoral votes
that is politically motivated even
though biden won
you're a republican and trump's a
republican and you want trump to be
president it's fundamentally political
and so it really loses its value to say
that the investigation is political well
if you mean that it's not based on fact
we can talk about that but writing it
off as politically
in the political sphere
has no meaning whatsoever when these are
politicians
trying to achieve political wins through
subterfuge and potentially criminality
and that's what's being investigated
they were politically motivated actions
that they took
and this is the same republican
projection that we've been following for
a long time i did something bad that was
politically motivated and then when you
investigate i'll say you are doing this
based on political motivation it's sort
of like democrats are going to commit
fraud
and try to take an election that the
voters don't really want them to win
well actually that's what you're doing
joe biden won and you were trying to
take an election that the voters didn't
actually want you to win and i would
just write it off as as pitiable
except this stuff is really effective
this stuff is effect i mean in the
aftermath of the 2020 election nearly 60
percent of republicans fell for it and
they believed actually donald trump won
we've been talking about how effective
these silly things are in the context of
herschel walker herschel walker's the
speaking of georgia
the senate republican nominee in georgia
facing off against the incumbent senator
rafael warnock
and
herschel walker doesn't want a debate
and i understand why because herschel
walker can't speak
and so
herschel walker is now starting to say
warnock won't debate me
and it's so predictable and it's so
pathetic and it's so absurd
but it works because the trumpists hear
warnock's the one who won't debate
and they will believe it and they will
repeat it and they won't allow it to
dissuade them from voting for a guy
herschel walker in november who quite
literally cannot explain anything he
cannot explain his view on anything he
can't speak
um so sadly
it's working for the right to say these
are politically motivated investigations
even if it means absolutely nothing
closing the loop on a couple of other
stories this is from like way uh it's
from the weekend at cpac in texas
a marjorie taylor green and actually
this may not have been at cpac i think
maybe it is maybe it isn't it was around
the time that cpac took place marjorie
taylor green is insisting
there were no trump rioters on january
6th
it was antifa
but she also says
that the trump people are being treated
poorly
by being held in pre-trial detention
well but so what real honest i'm always
honest about it i was upset that day i
was a brand new member of congress i'd
worked very hard on objecting to joe
biden's electoral college votes because
i believe that that was my role and what
i was what i wanted to do and yeah that
was her desire i believe it was the
right thing i would do it today and do
it tomorrow
but i was very upset i never expected
anything like that and when it happened
i thought this is the antifa and no one
can convince me it was so-called trump
supporters
but and and we know there's a lot wrong
there and i cannot wait for invest real
investigation is that what's going to
happen yeah we will be real but let me
say this though
and then marjorie taylor greene also
pointing out they will indeed do
investigations of
the investigation into january 6th if
they get into power in november
that i believe her i do believe that
she's actually telling the truth about
that
the weirdest thing about this
is that
marjorie taylor green
on the one hand wants us to believe
the people being investigated and
charged for the things they did on
january 6 2021
are being treated poorly
because they're trump supporters
but at the same time she insists
they weren't really trump supporters it
was antifa for which of course there is
no evidence whatsoever
so how could both be true how could it
be
that the trump supporters didn't do
anything on january 6th and also the
trump supporters from january 6 aren't
being treated correctly by the justice
system and by the jail system in which
they are being held in pre-trial
detention well
i'm sure she can find some way to
explain it to people who pay no
attention to reality it would probably
be something like well here's what
happened the vile is i'm pretend i'm a
[ __ ] right pretend i'm trying to figure
out a way to make both of these things
plausible
here's the way that they would do it
there were trumpists in dc on january
6th
but none of them committed any acts of
violence or property crime or anything
they weren't the writers
antifa did the riots and then law
enforcement arrested
innocent trump supporters who were there
just for the rally
and is treating them poorly
in bad conditions one guy without vegan
food in pre-trial detention i think
that's the way someone like marjorie
taylor green
puts the two stories together
it wasn't antifa
it was trump supporters
as if we didn't have already five or six
things happen this week that were
completely beyond parody
mike pillow you guys remember mike
lindell the ceo of mypillow we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah that guy
he has a new deadline
and
honestly at this point
is this just a joke because you can even
see steve bannon standing in the
background this was at cpac i'm pretty
confident over the weekend
again pillow says
the new deadline it's august 20 august
21 that's like ten nine eight nine ten
days from now
he says it's gonna happen we're gonna
see the biggest change the country has
ever seen
and even though he's put together what
15 20 different deadlines so far none of
which have gone anywhere
do people still believe this is it
possible someone is dumb enough to still
believe this i'm telling you after the
20th and the 21st of august the
aftermath of that you're gonna you're
gonna see the biggest change this
country has ever seen and you're gonna
also see judges i said this before
everyone says well mike what do you mean
the judges you go back a year and a half
not one judge looked at evidence except
for andrew county mission but he didn't
want to rule on it and those judges back
then they have families they have
neighbors they have grandchildren they
were afraid i'm telling you they were
afraid but in a year and a half later
after everyone's seen the destruction of
our country what's it what is so slow
that destruction have been the judges
how about those hundred if you have a
hundred people in your company you have
to take a shot and become a junkie
question one is does steve bannon have
any idea what pillow's talking about
question two is does the crowd just stop
that okay how about how about the judge
in florida that made the great ruling
about the mass mandates on airplanes
changed our huge how about roe v wade
huh
so listen if you are still credulously
believing this guy after the giga
millionth time that he has pulled this
act you just want to be taken for a ride
it's sort of like take my money what can
i donate to the audits to give me
something to donate to
this guy has been
first it was going to be by december of
2020 then january certainly by january
6. then by january 20th inauguration day
then it would be by march or april trump
was going to be back it was going to be
late spring it was going to be early
summer it was going to be august of 2021
then it was going to be thanksgiving
2021.
do you think that pillow even believes
this i have to tell you
from what people are telling me who know
this guy personally people in the media
and whatnot
he really seems to be off the off the
rails completely off the rails and he
may actually believe this stuff and it
doesn't seem to be untrue
that this entire thing flying around the
country with the machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines speaking at the rallies
everything it genuinely seems to have
have ruined his relationship with his
family
um so i'm increasingly of the mindset
that he does believe it let me know what
you think
we have a fantastic membership program
for the david pakman show we do an extra
show every day for our members and all
it takes to get access
is to sign up at joinpakman.com that's
it takes about a minute for someone of
average computer computer with average
computer proficiency
you can use the coupon code big voting
22 if you would like a discount and then
every single day you'll get the bonus
show
and you'll get the commercial free audio
and video feed of the show it's a
beautiful thing
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer
supported program which depends on
support from not other people but from
people like you people who might watch a
clip on youtube or listen to a podcast
or watch us on tv or listen on the radio
you can sign up for a membership at
joinpacman.com
and you can use the coupon code not
mandatory but available you can use the
coupon code big voting 22
to get yourself a discount
let's chat with people from the audience
so important i want to hear from you
without you i'm a guy in a room
and it's sad and nobody listens
so we do these calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord we're going to start today i
hope i'm pronouncing this correctly
with is it tanya from texas is that the
way it's pronounced
tanya from texas welcome you have to
unmute yourself
i've unmuted you but i can see you have
muted yourself tanya welcome
thank you so much
okay since the 2020 election i have had
a suspicion that the fact that biden won
the white house and republicans won the
senate had something to do with a whole
bunch of new voters coming out and not
voting down ballot
well hold on a second hold on a second
tanya democrats won the senate what do
you mean republicans won the senate i
mean i i mean um i'm
i'm nervous i'm sorry oh you're doing
great um what
with what everyone was running to
referring to as a mandate to work
together because
um
wait so let's take a step back tanya so
i can figure it out so yes in 2020
joe biden
won the white house and took it from
trump
democrats secured the senate with a
50-50 senate but kamala harris is the
tie-breaking vote and democrats
controlled the house are we on the same
page as far as that goes yes okay so
your question was
there was there was talk about this
mandate for for biden to work together
with the other side because of um
oh
tanya
oh my gosh i'm curious okay i'm gonna
just reduce it to this please your
thoughts on the fact that people need to
vote all the way down the ballot i never
hear anyone talking about it it seems
like it would have consequences
absolutely
we must all vote we must all vote all
the way down the ballot if you show up
and you check a box for senator in
november and then you don't do
congressperson you don't do
gubernatorial you don't do attorney
general secretary of state
state senate all of the i mean listen
you get to you you're going there once
and voting you might as well make your
voice heard on every single one of them
and people not doing that tanya
helps republicans sneak in these
extremists into local office so you
better be do your homework and be ready
to fill out your ballot fully and
completely please
yes i agree and i i wonder why that's
not a major topic of discussion i
appreciate your patience with me thank
you so much tanya it's been a pleasure
things are okay in texas
i'm hanging on in there and i'm i'm i'm
hoping for beethoven okay we're all
hoping all right thank you tanya very
much appreciate it
an important issue which we uh landed on
there
let's go next to adam from knoxville
tennessee adam welcome sir
hey david great to talk to you sir my
pleasure
hey i have a quick question about the
the raid on mar-a-lago sure
are we gonna get like a press release
from the fbi kind of detailing exactly
what the evidentiary basis was for the
raid i have absolutely no idea i have
absolutely no idea it um i mean listen
it's not a requirement that the fbi do
that
sometimes the fbi on prominent cases
will brief the public as of this
recording of you know you and me talking
now that has not been done i'm very
interested in knowing whether they
looked very strongly at elements of
bathrooms during the raid and it's just
not something that they're telling us so
i want more information
but honestly and and by the way listen
donald trump can release the search
warrant as well i know lara trump went
on fox news and said he doesn't have it
well he might not physically have it but
his lawyers obviously do he can release
the search warrant at any time to prove
how bogus it all was he's not chosen to
do that
yeah right and i you know i have some
friends on the right and i'm i'm a
little concerned
that the basis wasn't super strong
really like from an optics or political
standpoint the right is going to use it
as like kind of a like a martyr dumb for
trump well of course i mean they're
going to do that no matter what they've
they've already been saying he's the
biggest victim of anybody ever you know
all this different stuff that so that's
i where i agree they will say that
either way where i agree with you adam
is it would be really bad
if there was not a strong evidentiary
basis for this and so i am
giving the benefit of the doubt that if
the attorney general signed off on this
the fbi director signed off on it a
judge signed off on it
until proven otherwise i'm going to
assume that it was all done correctly
but if that's not the case i'll be the
first one here telling you that was not
done right
yep
perfect thank you can i ask you a quick
um cultural question sure follow-up
are you a fan of astor piazzolla
yeah yeah i mean in a casual sense i'm
not like a connoisseur of his music for
people wondering piazzolla was a very
very well-known
uh argentinian tango singer
and i don't know when do you know
offhand when he died how long has he
been not around
no it's been a while he played was he a
singer i thought he was more of he
played the bendignon um
is that even been a singer too yeah you
may be right he may not even have been a
singer but yeah i'm i'm a fan of
argentinian tango it's sort of in my
blood as they say
yeah astropiazzola is one of my favorite
musicians of all time so beautiful all
right well adam you sound like a man of
culture i appreciate it
thank you david thanks for the time adam
from knoxville very very strongly
participating in today's show you love
to hear it
why don't we go next to
oh you know who i want to speak to
hey snake from moscow welcome are you
there
hi can you hear me yeah you know snake
people in the audience were worried
about you
because we learned last week or the week
before
that a russian teacher
had been
prosecuted and sentenced for telling her
students
her view on what's going on in russia
and you and i when we last spoke you
said if the if the government figured
out who you were you're a teacher as
well that it could be very bad for you
but i'm so glad to find out that it is
not you that has been prosecuted and
sentenced
yeah unfortunately irene again has
received a five-year suspended sentence
yeah what makes this particular case
very heartbreaking is that
basically during the
uh i think it's called the discovery
stage of the case it was found out that
a group of eighth graders that she was
teaching they basically goaded her and
provoked her into that type of
conversation and then they submitted
the recording of that session with the
help of their parents
to the investigative committee of russia
which is
not great wow it's almost like
entrapment by by 13 year olds in a way
yeah i mean
you people usually think that oh
teenagers they're just you know they're
so innocent but no some teenagers are
not
benevolent they're outright malicious
and malevolent wow well what's on your
mind today snake
uh basically i just uh today is the
first day that uh i'm back on the server
and a bunch of people told me that you
all thought that i got arrested but no
i'm just down with covet again and oh
basically uh basically what i wanted to
tell you is a very
weird thing that has been happening in
the russian educational system when it
comes to higher education in
universities
this uh
this summer considering that they need
to
hold back the sympathies of all the
soldiers and all the policemen all of us
guardia russian government has created
special quotas for children
family members of those particular law
enforcement officers as well as special
quotas for
people that are being deported from
ukraine into russia basically it was a
card launch that allowed people to
enroll into any university onto any
program without passing any type of
exams that would signify that a person
has graduated from school
so
43 000 or more such quotas were created
across russian universities and
considering just how lenient this this
admissions process is for such people
from those categories it's really
surprising that those quotas have not
been filled at all for example in my
university we received 150 such quotas
we had 120 applications and only over 90
people actually got enrolled huh and
what do you think is going on why why
are people not not attending
first and foremost
another thing you have to know about the
admissions process in russia is that
you register for the admission process
using your pension number so every
person who achieves a certain age
receives a card called snills which is
your future pension uh
how do you say identification card for
your pension
so it's very very easy to dox a person
if you take their uh pension id number
and then look through various government
registries so i think that a lot of
those people got really scared that they
will be really heavily doxed and will
face some sort of retribution in the
society wow wow that's an incredible
situation snake one question for you i
recently finished reading an
extraordinary book by ben mcintyre about
a
russian
russian intelligence officer
who uh was spying
against russia for the uk named oleg
gordievsky is that a name you are
familiar with
unfortunately i'm not in that particular
period of historical studies but uh
i will try to email you if i find any
relevant information i'm very skeptical
of anybody that's a former spy because
spies can be bought and traded
on average oh yeah no this is a white
it's not uh no i'm not i'm just
wondering if it's like if people within
russia know about him because
internationally his story has been
extensively documented he's still alive
i think he's in his 70s but something to
look into snake
yeah i will i will look though so
mcintyre on guardian right
uh yes oleg gordievsky is my anglicized
pronunciation of the gentleman's name
okay thank you all right snake from
moscow stay safe out there a lot
happening a lot a lot a lot happening
let's go next to guillaume from montreal
guillaume i am anxiously and imminently
waiting to go to montreal i will be
there very very soon
hey david do you hear me i can hear you
find guillaume
thank you david for having me
a big fan been a been following you for
the last two years i believe thank you
and quite frankly if you do have a visit
around montreal just
make sure to let us know what event it's
about and i'll try to attend it's
actually just visiting family is what it
is it's there's no events planned right
now people asked would i be willing to
do a montreal meetup
i would in theory uh but it's you know
it's a lot to plan as i'm sure you can
imagine
yeah that's definitely that definitely
is plus the venues tend to be a bit a
bit more on the expensive side and
everything really
anyway my question is a bit of a
hypothetical and with a bit of a
preamble but i think it's an interesting
question
to provoke thought
okay if we can limit the preamble
because there's 40 people waiting to
chat that would be great a little what
that actually helps keeping that as a
hypothetical okay instead of assuming
that i have a secret method or something
okay
so the hypothetical is let's say in a
random
uh thrift store you find a copy of the
us constitution and that by reading it
you are granted the power to add one
amendment to it to fix most of the issue
in the long run probably
that the us is having
what would be the amendment you would
magically add to the constitution oh i
have i am terrible at these things i
mean we have so many problems in this
country
i don't know that there's one
i mean maybe it would relate to the
financing of politics but i these
questions are so tough because they're
so unrealistic and so i i don't know i
mean i think i would i would uh declare
myself dictator that would be the one
amendment that would fix all of our
problems guillaume i don't know
i know i've i know i've been thinking
about it and one that have been floating
about in my friend group regarding that
was
uh essentially forcing
uh term limits on anything that holds a
position of power so senate yeah that
occurred to me term just term limit
everything yeah so at the end of the day
you if you want to buy a politician you
have to buy more than one per decade so
make it expensive to buy politicians no
that's an interesting one yeah let me
devote more thought to it and i'll come
back with something more substantive
all right well on that lovely note thank
you for the call that's that's the only
question i had so have a great day and
uh
thanks for the great show you put your
you provide on a daily basis thank you
so much there is guillaume from montreal
we are going to take a very brief break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we will be right back to the phones
momentarily
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's go back to
discord and hear from a few more people
it's great to hear from people in the
audience particularly on a day like
today let's go to clark from portland
now is that portland maine or portland
oregon my friend
that's portland oregon oh okay yeah i
was i was actually just hopped in the
phone calls i didn't get time to ask her
to think of a question oh no um so just
send to someone else real quick oh my
god well can i ask you a question
absolutely are you familiar with hood
river
yeah i love hood river actually i i'm
i'm potentially scheduled to go to a
wedding there next year is this a place
i would enjoy you think
it's beautiful i'll tell you what it's
um it's kind of right in between it's
it's in the cascade gorge okay so it's
right in between the high desert and
kind of the coastal range and so it's a
really nice mix of temperate climate and
a more arid climate that's very
beautiful yeah gorgeous sound pretty
good i would i'm looking forward to that
then all right well good clark you think
of a question okay all right have a good
one david all right very good there's
clark from portland who did not have a
question but at least was able to answer
a little something for me let's go next
to mark from stockholm
mark welcome
hey am i am i good you are are you
swedish or are you an american in sweden
uh i am swedish actually beautiful i'm
not shocked to hear your perfect english
thank you
um yoga's fans get over anyway um so
despite my okay i hope that wasn't some
horribly racist statement no no i just
said no no i just said like i'm swedish
i promise okay very good i'm very good
um i wouldn't do that but um so like
despite you know my tone of voice i
actually do have like a really serious
question that i don't know if you feel
equipped to answer this but i'm just
gonna take a sean in the dark now okay
um so recently like you know myself i'm
like a libertarian socialist my mom
is
like leaning heavily towards like the
christian white nationalist far right
really and
yeah and i have like no idea how to
tackle this i don't know if i should be
you know if i should stand up for myself
because the thing is too like i came out
as pansexual to her and she's totally
just like
dismissive and rude about it despite the
fact that prior to this prior to
recently she actually was a pretty like
liberal leaning person
so if i understand correctly
your mom is a swedish white nationalist
and you i'm not going to hold on
then you can correct it and you are
a swedish libertarian socialist
pansexual and there's conflict now
yes wow um
that's a big matzo ball hanging out
there
i just want to like make it clear like
you know i'm not gonna label her or
anything i'm just saying that like she's
leaning heavily towards that i don't
know definitively what she would
identify as is that a big is that a
common movement in sweden because sweden
is has the stereotype of being so social
democracy left-wing you know
yeah well i'll put it this way so like
the the stereotype it actually adds feel
to the fire for a lot of like far-right
movements in sweden there actually is
like a major like pretty like
far right party in government right now
yeah the sweden democrats
um you know like they've definitely um
cannot like served the way
if you whatever like you know they
basically basically like benefited
greatly from this um huge
influx of people
you know looking at immigration and
saying like hey you know we're taking in
too many people
you know they look around like you know
they're people have even like posted
pictures on like swedish um subreddits
and [ __ ] it's like
you know it's like a picture okay now
let's watch the language because then
we're going to have to bleep it pat
please make it oh i'm not going to need
it i'm not going to say anything oh i
thought you just dropped an s-bomb did
you not just drop an s-bomb oh
no no no now you dropped another one
okay all right everybody let's uh
let's let's see if we can get away from
this i have no advice about the mom
thing question remind me what pansexual
is
so pansexual is essentially this idea
that i'm not limited to
gender when it comes to attraction so
like i've found
uh men women non-binary people
attractive that's basically the gist of
it and by the way sorry for like cursing
it's a force habit i'll try not to do it
no that's okay so basically pansexual
it's sort of like a whatever sexual any
adult
exactly got it it's got it it's like if
i find somebody attractive they're
attractive no matter what their gender
identity is beautiful all right well i
appreciate the call and the insights and
by the way
do you speak english with some of your
swedish friends like how do you speak
english so well it's so common in sweden
i i make youtube videos and i listen to
a lot of comedians from the us so i feel
like that's about it got it got it hey
and by the way this and we're now
getting off topic it is interesting
that in sweden everybody
speaks american english like you would
think being so close to the uk you might
everybody there might learn british
english but it's not the case
you would think and also i i was taught
like the uk version of english in school
but i never jived with it so i just kind
of like went along with like standard
like northern american english got it
got it all right very good well i really
appreciate the call and your insights
yeah no problem thanks for having me
here we go wow mark from stockholm
really i mean saying it all saying it
all and only two bleeps necessary i'm
gonna go to eric from cancun and i'm
doing this with significant trepidation
it's been a while since we heard from
eric from cancun eric welcome what do
you have for me today
eric from cancun you were on the air
welcome
and absolutely last opportunity for eric
from cancun who i know has an agenda
every time he speaks to me but
we can't hear him he's not speaking
hello hello david eric welcome welcome
welcome
amigo sorry my mic wasn't working i
fixed it right now i want to propose a
phone call because it seems i've seen
the comments of our calls and
many are asking if i could be a regular
and
that if we can make a sum called i can
give you the whole cake instead of just
crumbs slices and pieces of my mind
and what do you say you know eric i
don't know that my mind can handle
more ideas than what i get from you in
the short snippets i don't i don't know
that i could even i would be in recovery
mode constantly from your high level
ideas
um
okay
um
and in that case i'm just gonna ask you
and
is your child a boy or a girl
is my youtube channel a boy or a girl is
that your question
no in is your do you have a daughter or
a son oh oh sorry i thought you were
asking me the gender of my my channel my
child no uh es
um
um i'm very happy for you eric
that means a lot to me i appreciate that
do you have any parenting tips
and how do you do the himalayan style of
parenting i can explain it first you
gotta treat him like a prince like a
princess you gotta give it anything you
want to have the best life from zero to
five years old okay from
five to ten years old you gotta be
just get with her like a worker so you
don't spoil her because if you spoil her
then she will learn how to manipulate
you and others
right and you gotta give them
responsibilities so she knows where the
boundaries
right all right the himalayan style of
parenting that's very interesting eric
then from
from 10 to 15 you gotta treat her more
like an adult that you're gonna let her
express herself and have your own ideas
but don't
this too much because then she will not
want to tell you anything because she
will feel that you would not listen to
her right and then
from 15 to 20 to
up you get recurrent as an equal then
you are in the same level do you
comprendi
i understand perfectly and eric just by
the way is it okay that i'm feeding a
two-month-old pizza is that is that
allowed in the himalayan style of
parenting
um
i haven't seen it but even outside of
that i don't think so maybe around four
years old okay very good no pizza until
age four eric
muchisima gracias i really appreciate
your call today
all right thank you very much there is
eric from cancun
absolutely shot out of a canon i
genuinely thought he asked me the gender
of my youtube channel i mean gender is
so big these days
like i don't know maybe that's a thing
my channel has a gender let's go next to
i hope i pronounce this correctly
is it uh oh wait oh no no no this person
is actually just listening sorry sorry
sorry they don't want to be called on
that would have been a very very big
mistake
let's go next to pimbus
from chicago pimbus welcome
hi david can you hear me yes i can
how are you i'm doing well
um so i had a question on healthcare so
like i recently
broke a vertebrae in my back so i'm just
dealing with all of the
bills from the hospital and doctors and
all these different places i'm really
sorry to hear that how did that happen
i i don't know i just bent over and like
i thought i pulled something in my back
and but so we went to the i
ended up being so painful i couldn't um
get up or anything so we'd call an
ambulance anyways um the the doctor was
like you probably fell within the last
month or so and then
uh
i don't know bending over like you know
maybe at a hairline fracture hanging
over just kind of
did the deal but that's terrible
yeah it's honestly it's i've broken
other bones and it was the most painful
initially but the recovery has been
the fastest out of all the okay things
are broken
but uh yeah so anyways i'm just you know
dealing with all of the bills for
everything and
um my dad is actually was born in france
and my both of my grandparents still
live there and his main argument against
universal health care is that
the care that his parents receive in
france is not really ideal he seems to
think that
i don't know doctors aren't paid as much
there so they're not as motivated to
provide quality care
so i'm just curious if you have any
ideas of how i could maybe dispel that
notion to him that well listen this is a
very complicated issue you know i i
can't say that much about french doctors
but i know british doctors and they are
not paid as much that is absolutely true
now whether a british doctor will
provide inferior care
because an american doctor makes more
money that also doesn't really make
sense i mean if you're british and you
work in the uk and these are the
salaries i don't know that the fact that
some doctor in new york city is getting
more money is going to make you provide
inferior care that i'm not sure about
but i think
one of the things i would like to see
the left do
is to acknowledge
that
many countries that might have better
systems than the ones that we do
they don't necessarily have perfect
systems and you have to imagine a
triangle with three you know like it's a
triangle it has three points
where there are these three elements
you've got cost quality and access
and every system is trying to make a dot
somewhere between those three if you go
lower cost
and higher access that puts downward
pressure on quality all else being equal
if you have higher cost
and higher quality
then you you're pulling away from
everybody having access and every system
is basically trying to find a point on
that triangle
and the french system is not perfect
i've talked about the german system
before we've talked about the system in
singapore there's no perfect system the
point is do we want to prioritize
quality and in quality i include the
time you have to wait until you get
treatment do we want to prioritize
quality
and or cost
and or access and many countries do
better than us on any of those three or
even two of those
and then when you say well which
countries do better on all three then it
becomes a question of for what part of
the population and i don't know that you
know i don't know enough about the
french system to say specifically
but um it is not a shock to me that no
system is perfect we've known that for a
long time
do you have like a
a system that you think in like a
certain part of the world that we should
shoot for uh you just want to be able to
give him a good example the best thing
this is so
so everybody loves to just say single
payer boom that's it it's over
i've seen
very good results with systems that are
a combination
of
uh
non-profit
potentially
through employer or maybe not maybe it's
just employer subsidized but it's
non-profit and federally administered
with the option to
buy up or or buy into a private system
if you so please
with a safety net system where if you
just can't afford it you also you get
care anyway which some states in the
united states sort of have
and if i recall correctly i believe the
german system is sort of like that
but i'd have to re-up my scholarship on
the issue i've read a bunch of books
about it but it's been five years and so
it may not be accurate to say that it's
the german system that i'm thinking of
gotcha well thank you so much david my
pleasure absolutely great to hear from
you
let's see if we can squeeze in another
call what about cameron from seattle
washington cameron go
hello david can you hear me yes i can
nice um it was very nice to talk to you
on this fine morning
likewise did you have a question today
yes um i know that you've expressed your
interest in term limits for congressmen
but what do you think about term limits
for supreme court justices i'm in favor
of it as well
yes uh what what um how many years would
be
um
a good term
so one proposal i read suggests that 12
is a good number because with nine
supreme court justices you can create a
cycle that makes sense
overlapping it with four-year
presidential terms i don't know that 12
is actually the number but it could be
it was either 12 or 15.
yeah
that makes sense well yeah
yeah thank you for taking michael
appreciate it thank you very much and on
that note that does it for calls today i
am never able to speak to everyone and i
apologize for that but i will take calls
again and hope to hear from more of you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
get into the friday mailbag info at
davidpakman.com must be spelled
correctly not the info well actually it
all has to be spelled correctly but the
info part is the easy part it's my last
name that often trips people up you can
send questions comments criticisms
praise
try to keep the trolling to a minimum
even though there's always a little bit
and maybe that's where we will start
today first message is your y-o-u-r
an f wit pacman and they they say the
full thing with the f
you must support the loony left pedos
and pedos also with an apostrophe it's
all weird and it does contain the
required your you are confusion almost
exclusively
uh
almost unanimously in the hate mail that
i receive
and also
not a particularly substantive criticism
and this entire thing with left-wing
pedophilia not only is it like a strange
obsession for many on the right
it really actually seems like it's the
right that has a problem with this issue
but let's not make it political let's
just leave it at that
another message
not pleased with my commentary
i watched your insulting herschel walker
video and i gotta say as someone who had
worked with the developmentally disabled
and mentally ill
you should be ashamed i reported your
garbage commentary to facebook you do
realize people with brain injuries can
work
also wondering if walker was a democrat
would you have still said everything you
did yes guys
first of all
this person seems to be saying
herschel walker is developmentally
disabled or mentally ill or has a brain
injury which the right denies and now
this person is saying not only is it
true you're bad for bringing it up david
i was not making fun of anything
i was not
saying anything other than
this guy cannot speak
he cannot form a coherent sentence he
should obviously not be a valid
candidate to be one of 100 senators in
the united states whatever issues he's
dealing with if it's mental illness he
should get treatment if it's a brain
injury he should get treatment if it's a
developmental disability
full dignity and respect to all of it
and
his inability to express himself about
even one issue that is important to him
should make it so that no voter would
say this is the guy that needs to be a
senator
that's the point
and that's as far as it goes
next email is from sarah now i'm gonna
have to keep doing this
in order for people to understand what's
going on
sarah wrote to me and said possible scam
in your name david
i subscribe to the david pakman show
on youtube recently david included a
photo of himself with his child to which
i commented congratulations upon seeing
notifications later i noticed there was
a response supposedly by david but which
immediately raised my hackles as a scam
i've copied the text to include with
this email and it's someone that looks
like me
telling sarah to dm them on whatsapp i
want to make we are we are playing
whack-a-mole with these spammers okay
i am not trying to contact any of you by
what's app or text message i love all
the fans all the viewers the audience
love all of you
i'm not trying to text you i'm not
trying to whatsapp you i am too busy and
there are dozens of accounts using my
face if you can imagine a face like this
it's being used to scam people
into like eventually
it will be about they'll invest your
money for you or they need you know
whatever it's some financial scam so if
you see any account
that claims to be me
trying to get you to contact them or
saying i want to text you or whatever
report it for impersonation it is not me
i can talk to you if you call in
okay when we take live calls i am not
trying to text anybody love everybody
with peace and love i'm not trying to
whatsapp you i'm not trying to text you
all right sarah
matthias wrote in about monkey pox and
one of the things i really don't like
is when people criticize me for things i
didn't say i say plenty on the show
worthy of criticism criticize me for
that not for things i didn't say
mathias says sir
yesterday you mentioned it was
homophobic to bring up the fact that the
vast majority of monkey pox cases are
men who have sex with men
isn't it a disservice to be dishonest
with the gay community
i did not say
that it is homophobic to bring up the
fact that the majority of cases early on
were men who have sex with men
what i said was that it was homophobic
not to care about monkey pox
because you believe it is only affecting
gay men which is what marjorie taylor
green was saying
am i this poor a communicator that
people thought i was being homophobic or
sorry that i was saying it was
homophobic merely to point out a
statistic no that is not what i said
what i said was there are people on the
right
laughing this off like they laughed off
aids for a while
by saying i don't care about this it's
only affecting gay men and it is not
only affecting gay men i just actually
got a message from a woman
um who
has monkey pox and i guess now she's
over it actually she caught it two
months ago
um
come on guys come on
that criticize me for the things that
i'm saying
cma wrote to me about live golf
and says i have little confidence you'll
pay attention to this but i'm giving it
a shot
i saw your comments about the live golf
tournament please it is not live golf
it's 54 golf i expected much more of you
a cultured celebrity liv is a roman
number 54 liv
placing it in the name of the tournament
refers to the number of hits a player
would need to make if all the holes were
par or something like that please 54
golf not live golf
i have not heard a single
news report
sports channel
golfer or athlete call it 54 golf
okay
everyone's calling it live golf i get it
i understand roman numerals but i've not
heard it called 54 golf even once
so
it seems it would be weird
if all of a sudden i start calling it 54
golf i don't think anyone would have any
idea what i'm talking about all right
cma
so i want to be understood
that's the priority chris wrote in about
electric cars
a topic near and dear to my heart
chris says david thank you for
addressing the issue of right wing
disgust against electric cars and
similarly any type of green tech
i've been driving an electric car for
almost five years i've experienced
everything that you have and i agree
with everything that you said in this
segment if there was ever a litmus test
of right-wing intelligence or lack
thereof the reaction to electric cars is
it yet they really don't understand
anything another one that i'm hearing is
that they're saying
you know electric cars
you need metal
you need tires you need right but you
need those things with internal
combustion engines as well but at least
you're not burning fossil fuels when you
drive around i get it there's still a
carbon footprint to an electric car
nobody's denying that but
they seem increasingly desperate
ignorant
and unhinged in the criticism of
electric vehicles and by the way
no one's forcing you to go and get an
electric vehicle if you're happy
with
paying for gas and you know the noise of
internal combustion engines and all the
moving parts that can break and
stick with it no nobody's forcing you to
get an electric vehicle it's just as the
technology matures and the charging
network expands
and the vehicles improve and get cheaper
and cheaper
those internal combustion engines are
looking pretty antiquated i think that's
the main point
jason wrote in about fuel prices and has
another interesting take on the electric
vehicle discussion
jason says i don't own an electric
vehicle currently
and don't benefit from high prices
so high prices are a net negative for me
financially however based on the need to
reduce our dependence on fossil fuels
i'm actually to the point where i don't
want fuel prices to come down while i
don't want to see the oil corporation's
benefit i also think big picture we need
to reduce demand and use it in some way
tactically i don't know what it looks
like do you think there's any chance the
masses will understand how the need to
prioritize the existence of our species
or planet has to come before any
economic interest yeah i've mentioned
this before in a different context which
is
super high gas prices
aren't necessarily the best for oil
companies and gas stations long term
because they reduce demand
and uh
this is sort of what the point jason is
making
if gas prices are cartoonishly high
it makes electric vehicles comparatively
less expensive because it increases the
cost of ownership of a of a
a gas-powered vehicle and jason is
absolutely correct
absolutely correct
brian wrote in about 3d printed guns you
might remember that a home-made gun was
used in the assassination
of the former japanese prime minister
shinzo abe
and brian says if we can digitally keep
photocopiers from duplicating currency
why couldn't we use the same concept to
keep 3d printers from producing gun
parts make it recognize a part in any
plane and have updates just think and
keep up the great work yeah this this is
an important thing um
we have seen a lot of people on the
right
when presented with the obvious need for
gun safety regulations they go hey
listen
even if you get rid of guns
the guy in japan printed his gun at home
or made his gun at home so
getting rid of guns won't solve anything
well it would in the sense that most
people aren't going to be able to make a
gun at home
and the ones that are able to do it
aren't necessarily going to do it
because it's more work and people are
fundamentally lazy so obviously
will some people figure out a way to
print guns at home if you ban the
ability to buy a certain gun on the open
market yeah
but most of them are not
and then you get to the next question
which is
just because you could print a gun at
home even though most people won't
you can also regulate 3d printers
in some way and i know that you could
make the case well you can slice and
dice the parts thinner and thinner to
where they wouldn't be recognized as gun
parts okay i get it but the point is
you also can make it more difficult to
print a 3d gun at home for those that
have a 3d printer it's weird how they
act like we have no agency or ability to
control technology whatsoever everybody
will just print guns at home will they
well most people don't have printers and
even if they did you can also uh limit
some of the parts that can be printed
they just throw in the towel like we
have no more power uh the email is
absolutely correct
send me your thoughts questions comments
concerns demands for an apology
hopefully a legitimate demand to info
davidpakman.com
and the party doesn't have to stop now
we do have the bonus show every single
weekday oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves you can
sign up at joinpackman.com you can use
the coupon code big voting22
get the bonus show folks if alex jones
doesn't like it it should at least pique
your interest a little bit see you then